what up guys welcome to Pearl daily
where I go over this week's treachery
debauchery and craziness before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell that we
are going to be notified of my daily
videos a like is the most important
metric that sends out these videos guys
a like it's free so hit that like button
let's try to get this video to 2 000
likes so in today's news Andrew Tate has
another accuser now all of Andrew Tate's
accusers have been you know
um very reputable women that have no
history of lying that are just very very
honest and truthful as these women are
so recently there's a compilation that
goes into depth about one of the woman
who is Accused Andrew Tate of human
trafficking's history the two women who
have accused Andrew and Tristan have a
questionable past driven by by
aspirations for money and fame they
targeted the Tates as easy prey their
ambition was to become Tick-Tock stars
but when they failed to achieve their
dreams they reportedly resorted to
attempting to extort the Tates when
their extortion plan didn't work they
involved the authorities notably they
went on a luxurious holiday to the
French Rivera mere weeks after reporting
themselves as victims of human
trafficking this raises suspicions about
the authority of their claims
furthermore the source of funding for
this extravagant trip warrant scrutiny
if they financed it themselves it
suggests they were far from being
trafficked victims that may have been
making substantial amounts of money on
the other hand if someone else sponsored
their holiday in exchange for false
statements it raises serious questions
that demand answers
Romania
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
says Pearl
why don't you just believe women I mean
they look like very scared victims right
they're just oh so shocked and this is
the thing it's like when we start to
paint women as these innocent children
that just have no bodily autonomy and
are just coerced and manipulated into
doing things you're telling me a
stripper
really a stripper was coerced and
manipulated
into doing cam work because that is so
different than stripping
um and I I think we have gotten to a
place in society where we cannot
question alleged victims we are not
allowed to interrogate victims in the
public we are not allowed to interrogate
victims in the court of public opinion
if you go against women then you are
somehow breaking the sister code if you
go against women you're somehow
insensitive a bad person and it's like
why must we just believe
women
why do I have to believe a chick that
was a stripper when we all know like
half a strippers have some sort of
mental disorder going on anyway let's
just call it what it is guys like these
aren't the most stable people on the
planet and now we find out they go on a
luxury vacation right after all this
happens
um if you were human trafficked forced
to stay in a mansion against your will
I would imagine you were traumatized but
now you're out partying vacationing that
doesn't like this doesn't make sense to
me
this is weird this is not normal
behavior
so now Tate has another accuser an
ex-playboy model 32
a bit old as we know you know I don't
really think he's dating chicks over
19 remember that the video just kidding
but okay ex Playboy model 32 claims
Andrew Tate tried to lure her into his
Romanian Hideaway before he was
trafficked in rape and trafficking probe
now let's think our Playboy models
the most credible sources like why can
we not discredit women based on their
profession I'm sorry I am so tired of
this oh you can't discredit her what
she's telling is true well well sir
she's a stripper
sir she's an only fans model we are
absolutely allowed to discredit women
based on their profession and if
anything I think we should bring it back
so here we go
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Tate quote tweets this and says
I literally said go away I want to watch
the fight does this seem like a man a
man luring her into his rape and human
trafficking probe but but this is like
the craziness it's like these hot chicks
just live in delusion forever where they
can just literally say anything and
they're so used to nobody questioning
them they're so used to it like they're
just so used to men letting them say
damn near whatever they want and have
zero questions about it that's why
girls like Pearl gotta exist all these
red pill guys got to exist because this
is nonsense all of these men have let us
live in delusion for too long and I'm
really getting sick of it guys I'm I'm
getting tired
all right so I've recently
been triggering some people on Twitter
because I really do not think you should
expect monogamy from the top 20 percent
of it
now a lot of a lot of people will say
pearl
are you saying that all rich men cheat
no
but like can we just call it what it is
guys are millionaires and billionaires
known for being faithful
are rich handsome successful men known
for not having side chicks for being
family men
or is it usually that when they are
family men it comes out later that they
were cheating let's take Bill Gates for
years everyone's like this is a family
man
not a cheater
and then it comes out his wife lets him
go deal with his side chick once a year
now did his wife say oh bill but you
can't that is what no his wife
understood that's what came with it and
in a lot of these super rich men their
wives understand that's what comes with
it and I honestly am just really tired
of people exposing these cheating men
well we know rich men cheat they've
always cheated the top 15 percent of men
have always had harems of women and this
is not me putting a morality on it this
is not me saying this is a good thing or
a bad thing this is me saying all right
if you go for this type of guy this is
probably what you can expect and I think
as women it's better to just accept that
may happen and that you should stick it
out and that sex isn't the same for men
or for women I think that's a more
honest message than telling women to
live in this delusion where we expect
monogamy from the top 20 percent of men
I'm not saying you got to be happy about
it I'm not saying you should encourage
it I'm not even saying it's a good thing
but to tell women that that will never
happen when that's one of the leading
reasons people get divorced maybe it's
just something we should think could
happen maybe expect hope it doesn't
happen right not encouraged but the one
thing I was thinking about is women
broke the monogamy contract first women
will go off all day about men not being
monogamous but
what were only four percent of women are
saying that they're virgins on their
wedding day that's four percent so if
women are sleeping with multiple men
before marriage why it's almost like a
catch-22 where they say well I can do
what I want before marriage but after
marriage when men have the most sexual
Capital because men you know Peak around
like 35 right and even on some dating
apps say men peek at 50 where women Peak
at 21. so when women are at their sexual
Marketplace value at the highest like
when they have the most agency the most
power we don't pick marriage
because we keep pushing it off so it's
almost like a catch-22 where when women
have the most power we don't pick
monogamy but when men have the most
power they're expected to where it's
kind of become an unfair contract when
you think about it so there's a woman
that really talked about this a bit more
in depth
where how men are not programmed to be
monogamous where women are pull the clip
biologically sex is designed for one
main purpose procreation anything else
that's extra
the female reproductive cycle comes
around once a month for a man it's every
day
for each sexual act the woman's one egg
is matched by the man's 120 million
sperm cells now let's do some
calculation
120 million sperm cells a day every day
as opposed to one egg a month every
month means assuming all the cells are
viable that it will take only 30 men to
impregnate all the women in the world
this points to one clear fact a man is
by nature polygamous
monogamy and Fidelity are unnatural
situations promulgated by religious
beliefs and social pressures take those
away every man will cheat it's simply
biological now let's look at the extra
it's a known fact that women for the
most part are more emotional than men
so it's natural that after sexual
encounter she'll be attached but because
a man is Visual and logical in nature
there's no emotion involved for him it's
just a physical release that's got
nothing to do with love
a man loves his woman by protecting and
providing for her period it's really
quite simple for a man the physical and
the emotional two separate entities
thank you and that's honest and that's
what people think I'm like pushing
cheating or like saying this is a good
thing what I'm promoting is honesty and
the god to honest truth is that men will
screw damn near anything let's just call
it what it is all right and the honest
truth is that manner programmed to have
sex with a lot of people a lot of women
sorry but there's societal pressures and
there's religious pressures and I'm not
saying those are bad things monogamy is
a good thing however
I I do think it's dishonest to say men
aren't how they are and women aren't how
they are and there's a reason that the
men with money power look status
uh tend to have multiple women like I
don't and the funny thing is
relationships start nowadays
non-monogamous because you you guys have
heard me interview woman after woman on
the show most women will admit to being
in a situationship what is that it's
non-monogamy probably with the top 20
percent of men whether we want to admit
it's a thing women have had the most
sexual selection in the last hundred
years so in the past hundred years women
have had more mate selection than we
have ever had in history typically your
family would pick out your husband your
dad would pick out your husband your
brothers would help you find a husband
now women have complete control and
autonomy and it's actually interesting
because the the more control that women
have had the more mate selection women
have had the more women have picked
non-monogamy now I know what you're
saying Pearl what about the good women
Pearl what about what but the good women
don't pick that well are only four
percent of women go good
because 96 percent of women are not
virgins on their wedding days that is
non-monogamy now
and I think this is a lot more honest of
a conversation than you know just find a
good woman I think women are programmed
to get the best man they can and they'll
accept non-monogamy if that's the case
um and men are more are programmed to
screw a bunch of chicks monogamy is
supposed to be the middle ground we meet
on and The Exchange in value is that you
know the women come in as a virgin they
give the man Purity and they say okay I
could try to get the next highest guy
but I'm not going to do that I'm gonna
compromise I'm not gonna go for a higher
and higher guy I'm not gonna I will be
the Merchant's wife
I won't be the con the king's concubine
like I want and the guy says well I want
to impregnate the whole entire world but
you know since you came to me with this
Purity you're pretty young you're a
hottie all right I'll give that up I
won't screw the entire town I'll just
screw you and the women want to say well
hey why are you cheating which now women
are out cheating men that's a whole
different conversation but you know now
the women are coming in and saying Oh
but you break the monogamy contract but
when you think about it women broke the
monogamy contract first but whenever I
say a stat or have a conversation that
makes women look bad people get mad at
me
but I think it's the most important that
we live in reality I think we it is so
important that we fight for truth and we
live in reality so that leads me to a
skit that was done about this very about
this very topic and I want you guys to
pay attention to what people laugh at
because if we laugh at something usually
that means there's some truth in it pull
the clip maybe they were
they were a mess back
are you not introduce me hi I'm Haley uh
and you are even prettier in person than
in pictures my goodness you guys need
anything you having a good time I can go
get a smoothies okay well you know what
I'll leave you to be you kids have fun
and sweetie try the left hand yeah there
you go he likes that better okay
toodaloo it's like why is that funny
you know because she's because it's true
she would accept being
the king's concubine or the king's wife
with a bunch of Mistresses rather than
the peasant's wife and this just like is
what it is and what do the comments say
um leave him but don't leave his wallet
it's giving early 2000s Angelina Jolie
um the way I would actually be down for
this gives me time to go shopping alone
I gotta keep that money but but the
whole point is women aren't even denying
this women will tell you a guy can get
away with more of the better looking he
is the Richer he is now and I know the
gut reactions of tradcons is always but
what about women yeah but men know this
oh my gosh men know this men don't deny
this a woman gets away with more if
she's hotter yes the mid chicks we gotta
work harder than the hot chicks the hot
chicks are just born eights nines and
tens and they pretty much get to live in
la la land half their life but you know
it's like who's at the real Advantage
because everyone's looks go at some
point so when you when you think about
it it's like
I was thinking about this idea is Beauty
and Advantage like beauty is obviously
an advantage right for men and for women
more for women but when you think about
it like for the person you become at 80
is an individ is it an advantage to be
like treated special your whole life and
live in la la land and not have any
sense of reality tell your looks go at
like 45 or 50 as a chick
I don't know I don't know the guys will
probably still say yeah but I was
thinking about this thought like it
doesn't really give you the same
opportunity to develop like character
and other things
so who's to say the hot chicks are
really at an advantage
but then I look at these chicks on these
yachts and I'm like all right maybe
maybe the next question I have do women
like bad boys yes yes we do and this is
a Tale As Old As Time
why did we have the dad with the shotgun
that would tell the teenage the high
school boyfriend stay away from my
daughter why did why do we have that
because as women we like the bad boys
all right it just is what it is and you
know there's biological reasons we feel
the way we feel a guy that is aggressive
we know if he can be aggressive to
someone else he can protect us a guy
that can get a lot of chicks we know
that okay if all those women picked him
then there's a reason that they picked
him it's called pre-selection so now I'm
going to be covering a case where a
woman actually fell in love with a guy
who mugged her
[Music]
thank you
yeah so this attractive chick
was robbed and thought this is a man
with character that I should pick a
Brazilian woman brought new meaning to
crimes of passion after revealing she
fell in love with a Mugger who robbed
her and now the two have become
Inseparable the duo detailed their
alleged romantic Saga in a Twitter video
with over 232 000 views online I was
walking down the street where he lives
and unfortunately I was mugged the woman
identified as Emmanuela told reporters
recounting that their first date at a
media event in Brazil she recalled how
the thief took her phone but when he saw
in mela's number in there he said he had
been the one who had been robbed well
that's one way to get someone's phone
number meanwhile the unidentified phone
jack Jacker claimed that he had a change
of heart mid robbery I was going through
a difficult situation because I didn't
have a woman you know the robber said
recalling unlikely the how we met story
when I first saw her photo on the phone
I said to myself what a beautiful
brunette you don't see a brunette not
like that every day and I've regretted
stealing it so the reporter joke so you
stole her phone and her heart
the two have been dating for two years
and although it's unclear how her
parents felt about having an outlaw as
an in-law needless to say the Twitter
commentary was in hysterics over the
Duo's Love at First swipe it's only in
Brazil explained Brazilian journalist
Milton knobs on Twitter while detailing
their Bad Romance love can accomplish
anything so it's like as women are we
good pickers
do we have good judgment and they'll and
they'll say pearl you don't think women
should vote I mean this is what we
choose are we good like does this scream
logic and decision making
does this scream we're really good at
just the the decision making and like
picking and it's kind of funny how the
more Choice we've had the the last
hundred years the more we pick criminals
the more we have babies out of wedlock
the more we have abortions the more we
have multiple sex partners it's like
it's weird when women get like a choice
in anything we just choose chaos for
whatever reason
men dating single mothers comes with a
bunch of problems as a sister I would
never want my brother to date a mother
with a child I I really think that once
you have a kid you've kind of made your
bed you should lie in it if you get
lucky and find a husband that's great
but you're kind of done though like
honestly I really don't think you should
make a child with a man and not marry
him and I think you should never leave
if you have a kid with someone but there
is a single mother who recently was
dumped because her child was so poorly
behaved there is a clip going viral on
Instagram of a man dumping a chick for
her son
so why is you breaking up
why okay so so you're gonna break up
with me because of my son
making his gun though what you mean what
you say
I say this one so you gonna break up
with me because of my child he's just a
child he's bad dog she just need a
little guidance man
that's a petty reason to break up
everybody
so you just gonna throw all these years
down the drain
you know what the crazy thing about that
clip is the kid is actively
disrespecting the stepdad and she's not
doing anything he's swearing at him he's
shooting him with a a Nerf gun and the
mother doesn't do anything but I bet if
he disciplined the child
then World War III would break up
and this is the thing if if single
mothers want to be married they have to
give the stepdad authority to discipline
their kid it's not a fair deal it's
already an unfair deal coming into a
marriage with another man's kid and it
becomes even more unfair when now he
doesn't even have the authority to
discipline the child this is why a lot
of men will pass on single mothers
because they don't want to be
disrespected in their own house and at
the end of the day that child does not
his and now he's dealing with another
man's Mass another man's problem and
maybe that's an insensitive way to talk
about children but I'm sorry that's a
how that's how men see it and this is
just a whole headache that a lot of guys
don't want to sign up for or sign up for
without realizing what they're signing
up for
um and what percent of single mothers
would give full authority to The
Stepfather to discipline their kid would
allow The Stepfather to discipline their
kid even when they disagree with it and
this is why we keep going back to
responsibility the responsibility of
having that child without the authority
over it it's not a fair deal for men
it's the same thing with women having
the responsibility of looking after a
woman but not any authority over her
that it's not it's not a fair deal and
so my question is can we really blame
the men for not wanting to date single
mothers can we really blame the men for
not wanting to date older women and all
the problems that come with it I
personally think no and I think we
should really warn younger women that if
you get pregnant you've really made your
bed and your chance of having a
successful relationship after being a
single mother is low because one men
aren't going to want to date you and
even if they do it comes with these type
of problems that's a more honest message
than the simping and pandering that I
see today that oh men will still date
single mothers you could still get
remarried and all this stuff yes you can
and it can happen but you're really
shooting yourself in the foot and we
need to stop putting single motherhood
on a pedestal we need to stop putting
these women out of pedestal that we
should praise them when single mother
homes contribute to every problem in
society emotional men are a problem it
leads to homeless men it leads to men
with mental disorders it leads to men
that go to prison it leads to men that
commit suicide every problem that you
can look at in society really is linked
to single mother homes it is not linked
to single father homes so the question
is one why do women automatically get
custody and two why are we putting
single motherhood on a pedestal like
this is something that men should sign
up for when it is clear that these are
the issues that kid was not well behaved
and it's clear because he's had a decade
of living with a mother that does not
allow The Stepfather to discipline him
and is not getting proper discipline at
home young boys need discipline from
young men women cannot do it the same
way that men can that's why honestly
guys I think it's quite weird when you
see female bosses like yelling at young
men it's like such a weird dynamic to me
it's a weird dynamic to see like women
having power over men
um I I just think it's weird to look at
and I I think it's an improper Authority
structure but
maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm just sexist
maybe I'm just a misogynist I don't know
um
I I think I think it's actually meaner
to tell women that the proper Authority
structures that were equal to men and
have an equal say I think that's mean
because as women we damn near believe
anything you can really our minds are
basically like kid minds and they can
propagate us they can just make us
really believe damn near anything so I
think it's mean to tell women that we
are equal to men because it messes up
the authority structure in the home it
messes up the authority structure at
work and it has us live in this
delusional world where we think we're
equal to men when we are not we do not
bring equal value to the family and we
do not bring equal value to the society
because if we did we could do it on our
own if we were able to do that
if we brought equal value then we could
go off on our own
be single mothers and raise good kids
but that's not what happened if we
brought equal value to society then we
would go off and make these matriarchal
world powers with all of our brain power
because we're such geniuses
but we're not and that's the thing like
they have just told us that we're Queens
for so long they've told us they've even
brainwashed Us in the church telling us
oh we need to equally submit to our
husband guys we have to start calling
this [__] out anything that implies
we're equal is evil and it is
brainwashing and it is meant to break
down the family and break down Society
but guys maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm just
talking these conspiracy theories just
acting wild you know being this just
crazy chick you know maybe women should
overpower men maybe women are the queens
and the prize let me know in the
comments what you guys think like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time